and i do think even though it's
impossible some animal shapes taste
better than others that's it stop it you
do not think that sounds no i don't know
i'm not a lunatic that has to pretend a
different shape takes anxiety as soon as
i bite into a swedish fish i'm getting
anxiety but don't like the fact that i'm
going to have to do maintenance on my
teeth
seconds after i get your being you're
you're you're listen listen all good
things take effort and work it's a it's
a small price to pay for the glory of
the swedish fish and i'll tell you why
apply all good things take hard work
they do eating they do
swedish fish they do is the most unique
flavor of candy that is out there
because of the berry that it's based on
does not exist in this country animal
cracker you want animal crackers i'll
make you some give me some graham
crackers and leave them out leave them
out on the couch
leave them out on the counter for a week
and then when they start to go stale and
get soft that's what animal crackers are
you can't even do a hello fresh meal
you're gonna bake animal crackers from
scratch